he's an Indian composer singer
songwriter and music producer in a
notable two decade long Plus career he's
been credited with redefining the
contemporary Indian music film industry
his body of work for film and stage has
earned him the nickname as the Mozart of
his industry
he's AR Damon and here's my take on his
top ten rules to success rule number
three is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always guys if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it as well to other
people can be inspired also when you
write it down you're much more likely to
lock it in for yourself as well
enjoy
what is modernist rediscovering yourself
rediscovering the way music is done as
mom I do love to embrace new technology
and new ideas and especially like in the
film like Slumdog where Danny suggested
ma ma as someone you know in the
progression of music and everything so
it was like a two cultures meeting in a
way like some of the people who are very
close - oh what are they doing just
noise rats as noise and heavy metal is
noise so when you go into that frame of
you just try to like for what like
something for what it is not you know go
take a lens and disrupt explain analyze
it so with this philosophy I think I
kept moving on for like 18 years
rediscovering myself music has given me
everything respect Oscars Grammys and
you know love and money and fame and
everything so I'm an introvert I would
rather sit in a room do my music and you
know pray and sleep and that's my kind
of but how it pushed me to become this
personal a founder of a conservatory is
these incidents and after you become 40
of you you see that you're hitting a
wall you think that you are going
towards depth which is the question
which is a question which pushes many
people to start doing many things
because of the fear of not living when I
don't have a fear of I was fearless
because of that in a way and so even if
I fail in this attempt of doing this
music education thing let's find I've
tried something nice an effect your
success has been dramatic obviously and
coming from a city like Chennai of
course culturally very which we are in
in our own state of Tamil Nadu but more
importantly to be able to go global with
that has been just quite all inspiring
to be honest and made all of us so proud
here in Chennai but if you look at young
musicians today and what they are being
offered and
the technology it's moved along as well
what would you say to them I think
they'd have to find their own voice if
they found their own inner voice in the
moment we try to do somebody else's they
become a mediocre moment we try our
limitations are sometimes our places so
sometimes that forces you to think in a
way where there many millions of ways to
achieve a song of achieve greatness in
in art so you find a different way don't
have to you know if you a classic
example is Kumar then there were those
classical singer he had a lung problem
or something that so he couldn't sustain
his notes if you listen to his rendering
he would he would just make everything
shot he would like you never sustain a
because of breathing problem but that
became a great style you don't have to
copy that because it's limitation became
a style of what he could amazingly do
and it was unique the nice end so I
think all of us have limitations and you
should not think it's the limitation so
there's something else which is there a
plus within you and then bring that out
and then you become totally different
surely in the past you must have been
criticized by people and sometimes
people say some really harsh things how
do you deal with that criticism and what
advice will you give to other musicians
out there facing that you have to
elevate yourself to be the harshest
critic and when that comes in and so you
supersede every other critic and you
become a better critic than everybody
else you won't be bothered
the criticism which comes you've already
done it to yourself and you can say yeah
I know that I'm working on it in your
mind then there's a tough situation in
your life consider this idea slow down
your mind detach yourself from sadness
and always be bold to walk the path you
will certainly find relief solutions
breakthrough ideas and extraordinary
rewards but do not expect expect them
soon they will come to you at the right
time because if rewards comes too soon
you will not be able to handle it and it
could be a recipe for disaster
what is your advice and motivation for
young people who want to pursue a career
in music with what amount of knowledge
and content does one break through I
feel whatever first of all you need to
have a year for music you need to love
beautiful stuff then it becomes part of
you it's even more than spirituality or
music the same thing the more you start
getting into something and then you it
becomes you and so if you're
half-heartedly doing something and you
don't give enough time it's not worth it
if you don't even think about sustenance
nothing and I just go into it and become
a master of it
people will come following you and
that's the truth you know the pressure
must be enormous you know he's always
won an Academy Award the next time
around he were nominated for 127 hours
of course but hey you know I mean what
what is that feeling like I mean it's
like you know when you win a major
tournament and you come back the next
year everyone's looking to say oh we
couldn't win it again
which is not the case of course yeah for
me I think I made my mind realized that
- enough - is enough for your lifetime
and if anything comes as a bonus and so
your mind is not thinking but I watch it
thinking about art and so that's that's
a good thing I thought and I'm slowly
also become becoming more familiar with
visual stuff and kind of create concepts
the after point you have a monotony
people in India they have a format of
music which is give me five songs give
me six hours I'll make a movie
and then when you work with Bob Broadway
and Western everything you feel like how
are you guys doing they doing something
different they're going more deeper into
what could be achieved the manager book
so that forced me to and these long
flights to LA from the wine Emirates
I'll be thinking of how do you take
music to another sensible piece and it
is very challenging and putting a
challenge on yourself and you burdening
your son but then it's totally worth it
so I'm doing music videos now trying to
it's not an easy thing but it's keeping
me engaged and learning a lot I cannot
believe that it's over ten years since
my music and me have been associated at
Miami University
I've enjoyed collaborating with your
students your faculty particularly from
team global rhythms and above all every
interaction has allowed for greater
understanding sensitivity and growth I
feel humbled by the fact that so many
students here from another culture have
been have made my music part of their
lives learning from this experience has
allowed me to gain considerable
confidence in starting my own Western
classical conservatory in India
above all there are several miami
students who have come over to us as
mean making km music conservatory grow
in multiple ways and they have grown
themselves learning from our culture
back in south india learning through
travel keep an open mind and be ready to
receive things that come along the
journey so often we have an opinion from
someone or a place or culture before
heading to a destination each one of us
are made differently sometimes there are
many hidden truths of a place that never
revealed to us that are never revealed
to us till they experience it ourselves
what for you today is the challenge is
it the body of repeating yourself
ultimately it's all the same ok
something is catchy it it reaches the
public right and something is melodic
they recognize it but how can you give
it a different
forms where they don't feel like oh the
same thing for Tony right at the same
time you know musically explore even
take even more dangerous spot mm-hmm
let's see what what happens
I feel the thirst to learn is very very
important even now I feel like I'm not
learned enough and the nice certain
situations come in I said oh my god I
should have learnt music properly and I
should've learned counterpoint properly
the speed is what gets affected you know
you can do anything but then if you have
a very strong mind and well you can do
anything but at what speed can you do
and also when you learn something you
it also rivets you to one kind of
channel where you are specializing for
me it was I was always learning so I was
always moving from one thing to another
thing
so whatever fascinated me I kept moving
so my music was never routed to one
little thing
it had a probably people say my stamp
but then I kept moving
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Anushka asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it
down counts below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
your business what was your favorite
clip of the 10 and why please leave it
in comments below I'm super curious to
find out finally I want to give a quick
shout-out to Kaylee and Bradley thank
you guys so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting
that picture I really loved it it means
a lot to me I appreciate the support and
I hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
never rush into judgment especially
about people there are always another
side of the story a good sight we must
always find ways to see the beauty and
value of a person or or a place or an
institution or an art form and half the
problems of each of us can be solved if
people don't rush into judgment I think
like in every profession when you're
first learning to drive you're like oh I
should keep my clutch radiation put my
brakes lean after one of them you just
it's in you and you know exactly you'll
be doing multiple things that you're
driving so music is something that once
you learn the basics and you imbibe it
internalize it and after point of time
is only where you can connect to certain
things you can focus to certain things
which they want but it's sad as a sad
song when it's a spiritual musical then
you get the technology out on the
technicality out and you just go to
focus to what in you to achieve what are
the combinations of organic material you
need like a voice or an instrument and
what not to use how much less it should
be and how much epic it should be so all
these balances and what can what
tonality it should be like its own
vintage sounding modern sounding and all
these comes as an instinctive thing and
the other thing countries gets askew